all right George
who's your friend Debbie this is Debbie
this is Debbie Debbie's Debbie's cute
he's a cutie so we talked about this
this is a little bit ago but tell me
again so you met Debbie Howe uh well I
picked her up over in the warehouse I
stayed by some warehouses over in a
harbor area
and uh I guess they were they returned
from some people and uh they just had
like six of them so I picked up two at a
time
skateboard because they're so heavy
they're heavy right yeah they're
basically it's almost the weight of this
one's like 100 pounds I've had the the
big voluptuous lady is which is
160 at least oh so you have a bigger
girl yeah it's a bigger one it's
healthier everything he's gotta helps
your rack big booty small waist they're
they're anatomically correct yes yes
they are
very voluptuous one
Megan actually she was my first what I
had her with my girlfriend
Your Girlfriend yes I do and uh I
started off with the dog and my
girlfriend started playing with herself
and then then she was and I told her she
was Nexus so like how long have you had
uh Megan and uh within the last month